Also in meinen Augen hat sich das deutlich verschlimmert mit dem Geld. Als ich noch damals 17, 18 war, da war das normal, ohne Geld zu spielen.
Seit mindestens 15 Jahren mache ich das, nicht immer in den ganz großen Maßen, aber ich würde sagen 1,5 Millionen bis 2 Millionen sind also hier von meiner Seite aus in den Sport geflossen. Das will ich auch hoffen, dass sie abhängig sind von mir. Dann würde ich es nicht machen. Ja, warum soll ich das machen? Wenn die bestimmen können, was sie wollen, warum soll ich da Geld reinschießen? Das geht nicht. Nein, dann kann ich sie gleich im Fenster rausschmeißen.
Es wird schon ein kleines Erdbeben auslösen, denn wenn es schwarze Kassen gibt, wie in ihrem Bericht dargestellt, dann ist das per se schon ein Straftatbestand.
Nee, ich würde das ganz ähnlich definieren, dieses Problem. Also ich möchte eben auch nochmal zu bedenken geben, dass es ja an der Basis, wie man so schön sagt, durchaus Menschen gibt, die dieses Problem auch sehen und die dann in einer Arbeitsgruppe bei einem Landesverband mal was anstoßen wollen. Mal sagen wollen, okay, wir machen jetzt hier eine Arbeitsgruppe, wir wollen dieses Thema mal lösen. Und irgendwann muss das natürlich an die Verbandsspitze gehen. Und dann muss die Verbandsspitze etwas entscheiden, ob dann genügend Ressourcen weiterhin dafür zur Verfügung stehen oder ob das Thema größer gedacht wird oder nicht. Und da gibt es viele, viele Menschen, die eigentlich das Gute im Sinn haben und die eine Veränderung bewirken wollen, die aber dann eben an den Gegebenheiten scheitern in den Verbänden. Und das ist natürlich dann auch ein Problem. Wenn wir uns Führungsstrukturen anschauen, wenn wir uns tradierte Verhaltensweisen anschauen innerhalb der Verbände, das macht es ja dann nicht einfacher. Und wenn es jetzt eben Bestrebungen gibt innerhalb der Community des Amateurfußballs, die Situation zu verändern, dann sollte der Verein das auch, oder der Verband, Entschuldigung, sollte der Verband das ermöglichen. Denn ich glaube, es würde, wenn überhaupt, eher bottom-up als top-down geschehen, wenn sich da etwas verändert. Also das wird, wenn, dann eher von unten kommen, anstatt von oben.
Ja, interessanter Gedanke. Und gleichzeitig, und da kann ich wirklich nur jedem empfehlen, schaut euch diesen Film an. Ich sag's nochmal, Milliarden-Geschäft Amateurfußball, wenn das Geld im Umschlag kommt, ist heute Abend um 23.30 Uhr in der ARD zu sehen und in der Mediathek zu finden. Da habt ihr ja auch einen Investor und den haben wir auch im Intro gehört. Deswegen möchte ich nochmal kurz erklären, wen haben wir da eigentlich gehört. Das war Gerhard Klapp, Unternehmer und Millionär, der in seiner Region sechs Fußballvereine unterstützt und im Intro haben wir eben gehört, dass er sagt, er hat da eineinhalb bis zwei Millionen Euro hinein investiert und auf die Frage, ja aber sind denn diese Vereine nicht irgendwie von Ihnen abhängig, sagte er, ja das will ich aber doch sehr hoffen, weil ansonsten würde ich ja nicht investieren. Und das kann man sogar, finde ich, da muss man jetzt nicht Rollenspieler sein, um das aus seiner Sicht total nachvollziehen zu können. Aber das zeigt ja auch, welche abstruse Blüten das eben auch in den 5., 6., 7., Rundenliegen dieses Landes sprießen lässt. Denn im Grunde ist das nichts anderes, als wenn Martin Kind oder Dietmar Hopp oder irgendjemand anderes auch versucht, einem Bundesligisten als Investor so an sich zu binden, dass man die Entscheidungsbefugnis hat. Es ist halt nur in einer anderen Liga und so, dass wir es, wenn ihr nicht gerade einen Film drüber macht, nicht mitbekommen.
Ja, also das hat die Recherche auf jeden Fall ganz eindeutig gebracht. Die sogenannten Mini-Hopps, die immer mal wieder von Zeitungen dann entdeckt werden in den Regionen, die gibt es einfach und es wäre naiv, zu glauben, dass die jetzt gar nicht mitbestimmen, dass die einfach nur sagen, ich gebe immer das Geld, aber macht mal so, wie ihr meint. Das glaube ich nicht, das wird in den allerseltensten Fällen sicherlich auch mal der Fall sein. Aber auch Dietmar Hopp hat sich ja immer so ein bisschen, zumindest ich habe das mal eine Zeit lang verfolgt in den allerersten Jahren, als er auf dem Leim aufgestiegen ist in die Bundesliga, damals als Journalist und Dietmar Hopp hat sich ja auch immer so ein bisschen, ich mach doch gar nicht, ich gucke doch nur und ich stehe doch hier nur auf der Tribüne, aber im Hintergrund sitzt der Spielerberater, widmen in der Loge und da werden natürlich in solchen Logen dann auch immer mal wieder Fäden gezogen. Also die Leute mischen mit und das hat der Gerhard Klapp, der jetzt der mit zehn war, den wir ausgewählt haben, für diesen Film und der uns freundlicherweise eben auch, glaube ich, einen ganz guten Einblick in sein Tun gewährt hat.
Und sein Fuhrpark auch?
In seinen Fuhrpark am Rande und auch in seine Mannschaften und auch in die Gehälter, die gezahlt werden, das hat der also ganz klar gesagt.
Also wirklich, das fand ich so der Protagonist, der mir einfach jetzt in den Tagen, nach dem ich diese Doku gesehen habe, immer im Blick geblieben ist zusammen mit den Eintrachtwald Mittelbachern, den beiden, an die habe ich mich erinnert und Arne an jemanden, an den ich mich auch erinnert habe und den haben wir eben auch im Intro gehört, war Thomas Sommerer, ein Sportjurist, dem ihr eure Recherche vorgelegt habt und das habt prüfen lassen und der eben gesagt hat, naja, das könnte ein Erdbeben auslösen und er sagt nicht nur, dass den Vereinen der Entzug der Gemeinnützigkeit droht, sondern auch Spieler könnten Probleme kriegen, denn sie müssen auch Sachbezüge versteuern. Steuerhinterziehung, da gibt es bis zu fünf Jahren Freiheitsstrafe oder Geldstrafe, ohne jetzt davon ausgehen zu wollen, dass das jetzt auch schon ein realistisches Strafmaß mehr. Aber ich glaube, diesen Punkt muss man an der Stelle schon auch noch machen, wenn ein Finanzamt hinschaut und wenn ein Finanzamt sieht, hier wurde, so wie es ja offenbar in vielen Vereinen passiert oder dem Anschein nach in vielen Vereinen passiert, etwas nicht korrekt versteuert, dann betrifft das nicht nur den Verein, sondern es kann auch auf den Spieler zurückfallen.
Ganz genau, und das ist, glaube ich, eine der zentralen Themen auch, die uns dann beschäftigen muss. Das ist eben die Mischung aus Sportrecht und Stafrecht, die dann eben zum Tragen kommt. Natürlich weist die Spielordnung des DFB auch aus. Ich meine, ich mich zu erinnern, dass im schlimmsten Fall ein Verein auch bestraft werden kann für so etwas mit einem Punktabzug oder so, also dass halt da schon eine Möglichkeit besteht, müsste ich jetzt aber nochmal nachschauen, weiß nicht genau, aber andererseits im strafrechtlichen Bereich ist das natürlich auch alles relevant, also auf dem Papier wäre es ja schon so, wenn jetzt die Aufdeckungswahrscheinlichkeit viel viel höher wäre, dass dann theoretisch mehr Leute einfach bestraft werden würden und auch mehr Vereine Nachzahlungen leisten müssten. Jetzt haben wir eben schon diskutiert, warum das nicht der Fall ist, aber ich kann eben aus der Erfahrung schildern, dass wir mit vielen Betroffenen gesprochen haben, die das tatsächlich auch wissen, so und die das wissen, dass das Schwarzgeld ist, die das teilweise ärgert, die das teilweise aber auch eher mit Axelzucken dann hinnehmen, dass es so ist, weil sie eben schon erahnen, dass es eben nicht so leicht aufgedeckt werden kann und das ist eben ein juristischer Graubereich, in dem eben auch noch nicht so viel Rechtsprechung vorliegt. Wenn ich mich jetzt an die Gespräche mit Herrn Summerer erinnere, der hatte sich dann so verschiedenste Fallbeispiele angeschaut, die wir ihm aufbereitet hatten und ist dann eben zu diesem Schluss gekommen und das bringt eben dann noch mal eine weitere Komponente mit rein. Also wir hatten diese gesellschaftliche Komponente schon diskutiert, welche Rolle spielte Amateurfußball in Deutschland, wir hatten die sportliche Komponente, wir hatten die finanzielle Komponente und jetzt haben wir noch eine juristische Komponente. Das zeigt eben, wie komplex dieses Thema auch ist und wie viele unterschiedliche Bereiche unseres Lebens damit zu tun haben. Und letztinstanzlich, wenn ich mich der Steuerhinterziehung strafbar mache, dann begehe ich eben ein Verbrechen und das sollte schon jeder irgendwo wissen, denn wenn wir keine Steuern zahlen würden in unserer Gesellschaft, dann hätten wir ganz andere Probleme. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass jetzt hier die Steuern irgendwie an sich das Problem wären, sondern diese Gelder werden ja schon meistens zumindest an den Stellen eingesetzt, an denen sie gebraucht werden.
Außer Andreas Scheuer hat da irgendwie mitzureden, aber das ist jetzt eine ganz persönliche Meinung. Was wird denn jetzt eurer Meinung nach passieren oder was sind jetzt erstmal eure konkreten Pläne? Seid ihr jetzt schon komplett fertig mit eurer Recherche? Bleibt die Umfrage zum Beispiel offen? Es könnte ja jetzt auch sein, dass jetzt dann durch den ARD-Film angeregt sich ganz andere Leute noch mal bei euch melden. Wie geht es für euch weiter?
Also für uns ist es natürlich fast unmöglich, würde ich sagen, sich jetzt gleich davon zu trennen. Wir haben uns jetzt so intensiv damit beschäftigt. Das ist ja dann irgendwie fast ein kleines Baby, so eine Langzeitrecherche. Und wir verfolgen das jetzt, werden sicherlich auch zeitnah einmal berichten, möglicherweise schon am Wochenende mit ersten Reaktionen, wenn denn was passiert. Und werden das aber auch im Blick behalten. Und ich hoffe auch, dass sich weiterhin Leute bei uns melden, die ihre Erfahrungen mitteilen, die was zu sagen haben. Vielleicht jetzt auch keine Ahnung, soll jetzt hier kein Aufruf sein, aber es ist spannend. Warum nicht? Ja, warum nicht, stimmt. Wir wollen weiter mit den Leuten im Gespräch sein und von ihren Erfahrungen profitieren, unser Wissen erweitern. Und so können wir das eben journalistisch aufbereiten und journalistisch mit den Mitteln von Journalisten einordnen.
Bleibt die Umfrage offen?
Ja, wir hatten eben die Umfrage die ganze Zeit noch offen gelassen. Und da ist auch immer wieder dann irgendwas reingetrudelt, aber die wurde jetzt ja nicht mehr aktiv beworben. Aber grundsätzlich ist sie schon noch offen, das heißt also, wenn uns Leute etwas erzählen wollen, schreiben wollen, können sie das dort tun. Ich glaube, wir müssen sie mal so ein bisschen frisch machen wieder. Das ist jetzt tatsächlich in den letzten Monaten so ein bisschen liegen geblieben, weil wir eben andere Aufgaben hatten. Aber grundsätzlich ist es eben auch wichtig, dass man uns dann in irgendeiner Form erreichen kann, auch anonym. Weil das ist eben auch wichtig, so dieser Bereich der journalistischen Recherche, dass man anonym eben Sachen hinterlassen kann, Dokumente hochladen kann, Erfahrungsberichte teilen kann. Und natürlich das Bessere für uns ist natürlich, wenn Leute mit Kontaktdaten dort was hinterlassen, weil dann haben wir eben die Möglichkeit, mit den Leuten in Kontakt zu treten. Und das war eben kurz angeklungen, aber ich habe noch mal so grob überschlagen, wie viele Gespräche wir geführt hatten, so Telefongespräche. Und ich bin dann addiert irgendwo so zwischen 250 und 350 rausgekommen, also so plus minus. Und das zeigt so ein bisschen, wie viele Leute wir da wirklich genervt haben mit dem Thema zum Teil.
Jetzt kriegst du da einen Aufruf, Max. Also wirklich Expressis Verbis. Meldet euch gerne über diese Umfrage bei uns und das wird diskret behandelt. Nennt gerne, wenn ihr was zu sagen habt und nicht alles hinschreiben wollt, einen Kontakt, eine Kontaktmöglichkeit. Und was da geschrieben wird, wird definitiv nicht veröffentlicht, sondern nur, wenn solltet ihr da zustimmen, dass das veröffentlicht wird. Aber es ist wie gesagt einfach wichtig, dass man in Kontakt kommt.
Wird alles verlinkt werden in den Show Notes und dann schaut alle die Doku um 23.30 Uhr am Mittwoch, den 19. Januar in der ARD und natürlich auch in der Mediathek zu sehen. Und dann bin ich mal sehr gespannt, wie lange ihr an diesem Thema noch dran sein werdet. Ich bin auch schon gespannt, mit was ihr mich dann in anderthalb Jahren wieder überraschen werdet. Das scheint ja jetzt so ein neues Ding zu werden, dass ihr irgendwo den Teppich anhebt des Sports und dann darunter ein bisschen was findet, was manche als nicht sagt, ganz so sauber bezeichnen würden und dann sprechen wir hier im Rasenfunk drüber und ein Jahr später kommt ihr dann mit dem nächsten Teppicheck und bin immer gespannt. Oder wollt ihr schon verraten, woran ihr jetzt gerade arbeitet?
Nein, nein, nein. Wir sind jetzt erstmal noch hier, Gott bewahre.
Na, ich werde euch an euren Worten messen. Dann danke ich euch sehr, sehr herzlich für eure Zeit. Ich danke euch für den Aufwand, den ihr auch in diese Recherche gesteckt habt. Ich denke, das ist auch wichtig, nochmal zu betonen. Das ist nicht selbstverständlich. Schön, dass es dann sowas auch gibt, dass das in der ARD gezeigt werden kann und dass ihr das bei Eyeopening Media alles so verfolgen könnt. Das ist ein wichtiger Teil des deutschen Sportjournalismus. Ich danke euch beiden ganz herzlich. Arne Steinberg, et Steinberg unterstrich Arne auf Twitter. Danke dir Arne, dass du mal wieder mit dabei warst im Rasenfunk.
Vielen Dank an dich Max und liebe Grüße und danke nochmal an alle, die über den Rasenfunk an der Umfrage teilgenommen haben.
Ja, das schließe ich mich an. Und ganz herzlichen Dank an Wigbert Löer, der Ed Wigbert Löer auch auf Twitter. Ihr habt das schön einfach gehalten mit den Twitter-Händels. Danke dir, Wigbert.
Ja, vielen Dank auch an dich und an euch, alle, die jetzt zugehört haben.
Ja, euch danke ich auch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Danke für euren Support. Wie immer habe ich auch noch zwei Podcast-Empfehlungen am Ende dieser Folge, die jetzt einfach aus meinem persönlichen Podcast-Konsum der letzten Tage kommen. Zum einen, das passt sogar, der Sport Inside Podcast hat über Wettbetrug im Tennis eine Folge veröffentlicht. Die kann ich euch sehr ans Ohr legen und dann etwas komplett anderes. Der No-Fucking-Regrets-Podcast mit Rob Flimm von Machine Head hat John Petrucci von Dream Theater interviewt. Ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen nischig, mir persönlich hat die Folge aber sehr gut gefallen. Also diese beiden Podcast-Folgen möchte ich euch ans Ohr legen und ansonsten hören wir uns hier wieder im Rasenfunk in einem unserer Formate. Danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit, macht's gut!
Das war das Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch.
Wir gehen nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Punkhäuser.